hi I'm Nicolas be with reason TV and
today we're talking with Phil Harvey and
Lisa Conyers they're the author of the
new book the human cost of welfare how
the system hurts the people it's
supposed to help fellas chairman of dkt
International a group that provides
family planning and hiv/aids prevention
programs around the world and he's also
chairman of Adam and Eve the mail-order
catalog that sells sexually oriented
books and films is the author of several
previous books including the government
versus erotica which detailed his legal
battle with federal and state
prosecutors over selling sexually
explicit materials and showtime a novel
about a reality TV show gone wild I
should mention also too that Phil is a
patron of many libertarian organizations
including Reason Foundation the
nonprofit that publishes reason TV this
co-authored Lisa Conyers as a writer and
analyst at the DK teed Liberty project
which circulates reports studies and
op-eds on topics such as welfare policy
free speech and income inequality Lisa
and Phil welcome thank you your book is
about welfare and how it traps people
into a system first give a sense of the
range and the breadth of what of the
types of programs that we call welfare
what are some of them and overall what's
a what's a ballpark estimate of how much
money we're spending on welfare programs
the ballpark number on welfare
expenditures is seven hundred billion
dollars a year at the federal level and
when you add in state expenditures on
welfare and we're talking here just
about means-tested welfare programs not
entitlements like Social Security so
that seven hundred billion one of the
depressing things is to compare that to
the defense budget but that's only six
hundred trillion so welfare now exceeds
defense spending and and so it's it's
one of the single largest items then in
the federal budget and indeed it is and
one of the reasons the federal budget of
course is getting squeezed on on other
discretionary kinds of things so when we
talk about welfare what are the way you
know there's things like food stamps
what what are the other types of major
major programs that go into what we
welfare I mean a lot of people think of
welfare is just cash assistance and they
think of you know families getting a
check in the mail but for example food
stamps alone has 45 million people there
is public housing assistance there's
there's Medicaid
there's Obama phone which is actually a
phone system that is provided to poor
people but it's been around since Reagan
there before so it's not really the
wrong phone it's just that people have
heard about it and it's a welfare
program that helps people who otherwise
wouldn't have access to a phone now to a
cell phone and the I mean that they
could use it to apply for jobs or you
know just stay in contact with friends
and family talk a little bit about the
interviews that you did I mean there are
people all over the country to talk to
how did you find them how you know how
how did you locate them but then also
how did you find them mm-hm
well I traveled all over the country for
this book I went from Hawaii to
California in Washington State Oregon
Georgia South Dakota and basically I
wanted to know how it felt to actually
be on welfare you know you can read
about what the rules are how you think
it works but then you go out and
actually talk to people about how it
plays out in their real life and so I
would drive into a town and park it a
either soup kitchen or a public park or
bus stops and just look for people who
look like they'd be willing to talk and
sit down and ask them about their town
or you know tell me about this
neighborhood I'm new here I'm visiting
and I'm here writing a book and it's
about welfare would you be willing to
talk to me and I was really amazed at
how open people were to sharing their
stories and telling me about you know
what it was like to be on food stamps
how their Medicaid card worked what they
did with their cash assistance the two
things that struck me was first off is
how incredibly complex all of these
systems seem to be it's a you know -
yeah I mean there were there are people
to go out and recruit people to be on
welfare and whatnot but the systems
themselves seem very complicated and
then how both kind of ingenious and I
don't even mean that in a negative way
but how kind of smart - people are like
they totally know the systems and if you
could talk a little bit maybe in a
general way of they know when if they
you know if they hit a certain threshold
they're going to lose more benefits and
they would gain from having
job or something like talk a little bit
about their the mindset that they used
to calculate their total benefits
package
well they do they would I mean I have
called it doing the math because they
really would they knew exactly down to
the penny how much they would get based
on you know which programs they were in
and how much income they had coming in
and it was actually frightening for them
sometimes to think about Oh taking that
extra hour of work or you know taking
that raise because then they would lose
their benefits because they knew you
know if I go over this line by even a
dollar I could lose my food stamp
benefit I could lose my housing benefit
and when you're not when you're at those
low level jobs that might come and go it
can be kind of scary to take on the
extra income because then you're losing
quite a big benefit that's pretty
dependable so most the people I met knew
exactly how much they could make and
they knew how much they were getting
every month and they relied on it and
it's small sums of money but it's really
important when it's what you're living
on what would you say is how often do
people are is is there a set percentage
you could say that people on welfare on
some type of assistance go into a gray
market so they're working you know above
board and whatnot but then because they
know that next dollar is going to kill
me on my benefits and then they start
doing stuff off the books oh yeah I
think off the books work is very very
common I don't think I met anybody that
wasn't doing some kind of off-the-books
work and and people trade and barter a
lot I mean they trade babysitting for
car maintenance for a place to sleep for
or they'll sell their food stamps you
know in order to get some cash to go pay
for something so there's a very very
active underground economy the
off-the-books part I find rather
encouraging because it people want to
work when they want to earn money they
just don't want to lose their benefits
and I think one of the worst things
about the welfare system is that in it
induces this psychology of fear of
earning too much the prospect of having
all your benefits cut off or some are a
significant part of your benefits are
cut off makes people look
earning income as risky how did that
come to be a defining kind of
characteristic of the system because the
whole idea of work of welfare reform in
the 90s was that it was supposed to be
work fair it was going to be time
limited it was going to push people to
work which is what everybody wants you
nobody wants to be dependent and yet now
you're saying that you know people don't
want to work or they realize that work
is risky that obviously means that
something is terribly wrong in the
system
well the reforms of 1996 which were real
and to a considerable extent effective
we're in the 8th aid to families with
dependent children which was transformed
into a program as you suggest that was
time limited the required work that
offered some training and job placement
but what has happened is that that
program is now about two or three
percent of the total welfare package
it's still there it still has work
requirements but food stamps are much
much bigger no work requirements they're
the combination of these programs for
people who are eligible for them provide
sufficient income to get by but induce a
sense of entrapment
because of the fear of having them cut
off if they earn too much money or if
the caseworker finds out that they are
horror of Horrors actually earning more
money than they're supposed to let's
talk about housing assistance you guys
write that and I'm quoting here
subsidized housing is a major component
of the u.s. federal welfare system with
the cost of the program doubling between
1990 and 2010 even though the number of
recipients has stayed about the same how
how does housing assistance hurt the
poor well probably the biggest problem
with housing assistance is that people
are in public housing that no longer
qualify for it and the reason for that
is because
the way the system was designed was with
the idea that we want people to have a
stable place to live and then they can
work on finding jobs and getting working
their way out of poverty and so we
didn't have the kind of checking in and
making sure that you're still on
benefits that we have with other
programs so for example in my travels I
met people often who said that they had
no hope of getting into the public
housing in the towns or cities that they
lived in because they were completely
full and in many cases full with people
who no longer actually qualified for the
program but there was nobody telling
them to move out so there was no
follow-up to say okay you you're not
making it and so now you should find
your own place yeah and I met one young
gallon in the Bronx and she told me a
story of her aunt who had been in the
same public housing unit for 30 years
and had moved in and out of it rented it
out to other people had long since
stopped being in poverty but no one had
ever checked on her I mean while this
young gal had two kids and really needed
the program and was told that she was on
a waiting list that was ten years long
some original abuse is there I mean if
you if you qualify for housing and then
live in it for a couple of years and you
don't qualify anymore and you rent it
out to your relatives or to somebody
else and you can work your way out of
poverty just as a landlord renting out a
piece of housing that you're not
supposed to have that happens then again
you're right that's pretty inventive I
mean it's a sign of somebody you know if
they were applying that uh ingenuity to
the actual economy it'd be a good thing
Medicaid is health care for the poor and
it's paid for jointly by the states and
the federal government it's a massive
expense in most states Medicaid is
always either the first or second
biggest thing that they they spend money
on and now if you make a certain salary
you don't qualify for Medicaid and a
host of other programs and then you
quoted in a book woman named Annie a
mother of two in Oregon who said I'm not
going to find a job that pays enough to
make up for the value of my Medicaid
coverage for me and my two kids and this
refrain comes up again and again
recipients realize that they're going to
lose a lot more than a little bit they
would gain from
money is is that a ubiquitous problem in
these means-tested programs and then how
how do you deal with that because you
know you need to have a cut-off right
for people where okay you're not getting
assistance anymore but how do you how do
you change that kind of plateau where
people just drop off the face of the
earth if they make a little bit more
well to begin with it you you have to
deal with the culture of the system the
culture of the system is geared to
maintaining itself the people who work
in the welfare business their jobs
depend on it
they have very little incentive to get
people out of welfare and into jobs they
just they they lose some of their
potential income as a result of that one
of the most telling stories that came
out of this process is a man of about
thirty thirty-five and an angel who
related his visits to his welfare office
says you go in there's nothing about
jobs he said you go in on a bulletin
board
need food stamps need help with Medicaid
he said everything is geared in in the
whole system to more welfare different
welfare they should put up a sign he
said is it twelve jobs available this
week in this communities it never
happens so the culture of the of the
system is anti job Pro more welfare and
the only way to change that it seems to
me I mean part of the way is to make
work pay as an e ITC which which we do
need to address but part of it is to
make work looking for work training for
work the part of every one of these
programs you call the Earned Income Tax
Credit Welfare done almost right
describe it for us and then explain you
know why it's not quite done right well
the idea instant is to make work pay by
topping up the wages of very low income
people and we think that makes sense
and
a fairly complicated way to approach it
because it is done through the income
tax system originally designed to repay
income tax withheld from low-income
people now if you're working and your
income is low enough you're going to get
in effect your wages topped up this is I
think the the right approach we think it
would work much much better if instead
of having to file an income tax return
in March or April every year these funds
were simply made available every pay
period so that people would would be
taking home a bigger check rather than
going through the rather complicated IRS
system sometimes with the help of
agencies that are not entirely ethical
in all cases and it only is the EITC
on't basically only available either to
married couples or people with fewer
children I mean this is the other really
big flaw and both conservatives and
liberals most recently President Obama
himself said this is a big mistake we
ought to make a ITC available much more
generously for the childless Phil is a
good libertarian you know like social
engineering through the tax code for
sure so yeah why should people with with
kids get extra money but why should if
you're an able-bodied single person why
should you be getting any kind of
welfare whether it's done through the
tax code or not the whole concept of
welfare to to libertarians is
troublesome of course it's it's
troublesome in that you are patronizing
people by taking money from some people
and giving it to others for starters and
it is certainly a patronizing when we
say you can't have this money unless you
do a B and C which is what I'm
suggesting and I do so with with
attached reluctance it's a little like a
parent saying to a child yeah you can
get your $25 allowance but only if you
pick up your room that kind of
patronizing behavior to us libertarians
is repugnant but in the situation that
we have now it is better to put
conditions on on welfare payments than
to simply go on dishing them out and
perpetuating poverty in the ways that
that we have described you know we live
in a world now where we expect our
worker most of us expect our work to be
expressive of our values and of our
lifestyle and what we care about or who
we are is that you know how do you bring
that down to a lower level of you know
service economy or jobs that generally
are not particularly you know that
glamorous it seems well I think that any
job is better than no job and most of
the people that I interviewed that said
they'd rather be working it wasn't they
didn't want to be on welfare that was
not how they envisioned their life would
be
I heard that phrase over and over again
that I thought I was going to be part of
the American Dream I was going to have a
house I was gonna have a car and two
little kids and go to work every day and
now I'm just surviving
I'm just getting by on these checks that
come in the mail and and all of them
said you know I would rather be the one
buying stuff for my kids I would rather
be the one paying the rent you know I
don't want to be in this situation
there's no hope here and so I think the
argument that it has to be a glamorous
job of some kind isn't necessarily
accurate I think that most people I mean
remember your first jobs my first jobs
Phil's first jobs probably weren't the
most exciting jobs in the world but they
were I look back on them as incredibly
rewarding that first check no matter
what you did to get it was more
rewarding than getting something in the
mail and and so I think that's part of
it and the other part is the more people
we can get to work then they start
working on their own careers and that's
where that that pleasure of working hard
at something and well working your way
up comes about but it doesn't come about
by sitting at home and just taking
benefits and and not working people have
an innate desire to accomplish things
everybody wants to be able to say I did
that I fed my kids I put shoes on the
baby I brought home a paycheck there are
different ways of accomplishing that in
life but for most people earning money
at a job is an important component of it
when you take that away you take away
dignity you take away a sense of
self-worth when you're accepting money
from some source that you know you could
never repay
that's bad for people they don't like it
you have an unrepairable death so that
when we talk about the issue of
happiness in the early part of the book
and the importance of work to do just
fundamental human happiness lease is
absolutely right it doesn't matter if
it's a lousy job any job is better than
no job all right well we will leave it
there
I want to thank Phil Harvey and Lisa
Conyers for talking to Reason TV they
are the authors of the new book the
human cost of welfare how the system
hurts the people it's supposed to help
for is on TV I'm Nick Gillespie